I know you've got coming up next and
kind of keys wrist roll having you in
the in the Sweeney at the very British
Film tell us a little bit about that
yeah I play a mr. fear mr. fixit's you
know in a man in the shadows I'm an old
friend of the character that Ray plays
and if you need false documents if you
need a pistol you need to get rid of
some gold I'm the man that can fix it
for you it's a nice character to play
it's very different isn't it to the
original TV series in the sense that
obviously we're in modern-day London
everything's very kind of high-tech it's
very swish the kind of offices and
everything they're in what do you think
about that take on the original series
well I mean this is it sells on the name
the Swaney people fill in but I mean
there's 40 years difference so you know
nobody had mobile phones Tony for
instance you know I mean London was this
built up the guy that directed Nick love
has made a wonderful job of a shooting
in London great job yeah it looks really
fantastic
you